with this we come to the end of the
Colorado series and in my last lecture
we have looked at the sidelines which is
Bishop takes Knight and the Knight takes
Knight in this video we are going to
look the final move which is the Bishop
to d2 and this is one of the main line
of the Colorado gambit against this I am
going to propose you play Knight to e4
and here you can see I have highlighted
by the arrows White has five good
options and we are going to look each
byte on so the faster the less dangerous
option is Knight takes c6 well against
this the very simple reply by the black
will be Knight takes c3 and you can see
it's attacking bishop as well as the
Queen and that means the game is almost
over this has happened in one of my game
and after long thinking my opponent
decided to play this more witches Knight
takes a seven but his idea is probably
to play rook to be even if I capture
that bishop with the night but I simply
diffuse everything with the move c6 and
now the three pieces are hanging and in
the game white come out with this
sequence which is quintus even but up
Quinn takes and rook takes and Knight
takes bishop and Knight takes Knight and
pawn takes Knight I imagine a clear
piece of so
Knight takes c6 is a completely rubbish
mall
the other move white has tried is Bishop
takes c6 well afterwards black will
recapture and again the nikes hanging so
white has to pretty much take this knife
and here I recommend that black should
play a very cunning move Queen takes d4
and now you can see black has a few
options which Knight is going to take so
the only logical reply from the white
here is Knight takes c6 which attack the
Queen and after Queen takes Knight with
the check white block the check with the
Queen I got this position in just one
game it continues like this so I played
the move Queen takes g2 and here my
opponent castle on the Queen side and I
payed Queen back to g6 so my name is
very simple not only I'm attacking the
knight but also attacking the c2 point
so my opponent wisely defended both the
things with Knight to d4 and here I
played the move rook to be even now if
my opponent take the bishop I'm more
than happy because I'm a pawn of in fact
couple of pawns up so that won't bother
me
so in the game my opponent decided to
play rook to be one but it turns out
that it's a big mistake because now I
played the move Queen to b6 my thread is
very simple I want to checkmate white on
b1 so my opponent come out with a
logical reply which is blocking the file
Knight to b3 and here I continue with
the move Queen to c6 so once again
creating a checkmate threat and if my
opponent would have to play the moves
such as night to d4 which looks logical
move because it's attacking both the
piece but then black has a wonderful
reply which is Queen to c5 and white
cannot capture the bishop because Queen
to a3 check is looming which leads to
the checkmate
so that's why in the game after Queen to
c6 my opponent decided to play the move
c3 but again this turns out very
weakening move and I exploit this with a
very cunning more itself the mo e six
and hear my opponent made the final
blunder which is night to d4 which looks
again attacking the both the piece but
can you spot it
yep it's Bishop to e3
it's a checkmate so that is one sample
line which give you a highlight how you
can play against Bishop takes c6
now the third more I want to consider is
rope to be one afterwards black response
is pretty much forced so black has to
capture this night and you can see that
night is attacking both the pieces so
here to mousse has been try in first
game
my opponent tried Luke Ross b2 but very
simple after Knight takes Queen and King
takes Knight I played the move Bishop
back to D cell so I'm protecting that
night and the game continues like this
so my opponent captured this night and
after i recaptured with the bishop he
decided to play rook to even so his idea
is very simple because black is lagging
in development so meanwhile white is
activating his major pieces but here I
decided to do a very good point
sacrifice and in fact when I check with
the engine that's the most move he has
recommended so here I played the movie 6
and after very logical Knight takes
Bishop and pawn takes Knight my opponent
grabbed the pawn and that allow me to
free up my all the pieces so I played
King to d7 and after rube goes back to
the even I
Bishop to d6 and you can see not only my
rooks are connected now but this two
rooks of the white are not coordinating
properly and that is the feature of this
game so the game continues with the move
rook to b7 in a way white wants to tied
up my ropes but I simply diffuse
everything with a move c5 and after
Bishop to e3 I capture that pole and
after white recapture I played the move
group has to be eight and now you can
see the drawback of the Roku's this
other would like to join this roof but
the king is sitting in between so
forcefully White has to capture this
book and after I recaptured the amazing
thing is I'm giving opportunity for
white to capture either of my porn but
the thing is whether white captured like
my a seven pawn or the g7 pawn the group
will follow that Bishop and on the same
time I will regain the another side born
so for example in the game
my opponent decided to grab the g7 pawn
but after very simple root 2 g8
attacking the bishop and Bishop drop
backs to them
d 4i first of all hit the bishop one
more time with the move C file and after
Bishop to d4 I just captured the pawn
and now it's a reverse like White has a
two hanging pawn so after long thinking
my opponent come out with this only good
move f4 but I simply capture the ball
and that means that this H pawn is a
winner of the game and in the game my
opponent tried some tactics so he played
the move f5 which invited me to capture
the bishop but I wisely avoid everything
and I played the move looked at six yeah
now white is losing the game continues
with King to d2 but now I capture this
bishop and after rook captures I first
of all consolidate my position with the
move K to D 6 and after rook
d 3 I played the move a 6 so I just want
to protect all of my pawns so there is
no tactics exist for the white and after
a 4 I now played the move rook to f6 and
after rook to f3 and h5 you can see not
only black is going forward with
Ashbourne but king will come to the Fi
and F pawn will also drop so this was
one of the nice game in this line which
give you an illustration how you can
play for the win the another try was
done by one of my friend who has done
some research on this line and he come
out with this move which is Queen Jack
and after forcefully Black has to block
this check with the pawn now white
capture the screen and his idea is my
pawn structures are misplaced and in a
way White has an active position well
yes in some way it's true but that
doesn't mean that black has no chances
and following game will show you how
black can continue for the winning
position I capture the Queen and now in
the view of Black Knight is capturing
the bishop if I decided to capture the
night
now I force the pace with the move a 6
so my opponent capture my knight and
after I recapture he finally grabbed the
ponceau Knight takes c6 which allow me
to free apply all the pieces so I played
look to
GA so attacking the g2 pawn and after g3
I played the move Bishop to g7 so I give
back the pawn but in return I get all of
my pieces active and that turns out very
good for me so here wide obviously
castle on the Kings side and I played
the move King to d7 and here to Knight
moves has been try and the first game my
opponent riot night to be four after
very simple King to d6 and rookie even I
played the move at four and not only
black will dissolve the double bond but
black has a two wonderful bishop and I
managed to win the game comfortably so
night to b4 is not a good move in
another game my opponent tried Knight to
e5 check but I just simply capture this
night and after white recaptured
although black has reached the opposite
color pending this position is more
favorable to the black so in the game I
decided to play the move C file and
after rook check my King comes to the e6
and after further look Jack my King goes
to the f7 so now planning is very simple
I want to play the move d4 so my
opponent wisely played the move Bishop
to b2
when I played the Moody for anyways and
here my opponent tried to grab the loose
pawn on c5 so he played the move rook to
c6
but now I exchange the rooks so I played
rook G to see it and after rook captures
and rook captures now my opponent played
to move c3 so you just want to isolate
my phone so he can target them but it's
not easy because you know white rook is
not active so that's why it's very hard
for Y to generate any sort of conflict
so here I played the move Queen to e6 so
attacking the lose e5 pawn and after f4
I played the move hope to be it and I'm
first on getting the open file and here
my opponent captured the pawn and after
I recapture he played the move rook to
d1 again it's what it was a rapid game
and my opponent was in the time trouble
right now so you can see the last move
was not that accurate and I exploit that
with the bow Bishop to g4 and after rook
to Sivan I played
to beat
I managed to win the apron and that
means so black hazard to passes and in
the game white cannot stop both of them
so I managed to win the game so that
game will give you a highlight that how
you can play for win in night we finally